in this video you're going to learn how
to solve systems of equations involving
three variables and three equations
we're gonna use the elimination method
I'm going to show you how to do this
step by step so this is the system we're
going to solve and the first thing you
want to decide is you know what variable
do you want to eliminate do you want to
eliminate the x's do you want to
eliminate the Y's do you want to
luminate the Z's well we're going to do
is we're just going to pick one of the
variables it doesn't matter which one
you pick sometimes one is easier to
eliminate than another
and what we're going to do is we're
going to eliminate the axis so you can
see here if we add the first and second
equation together we get X plus negative
x is zero so those cancel one another
out 2y plus 1 y is 3y negative Z plus 4z
is positive 3 z and 5 plus 10 is 15 so
all we did was add the two equations
together the first and second equation
but we want to use all three equations
so a mistake sometimes students you know
do is they forget that they have to use
all three so we want to combine this
third equation with the second one or
with the first one it doesn't matter
which one I'm going to combine it with
the middle one here and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to multiply this
whole equation by 2 and the reason is is
you'll see in just a moment I'm going to
get negative 2x when I add that to this
one that the positive 2x holes are going
to cancel so we get negative 2x plus 2y
plus 8 Z is equal to 20 and if we just
bring this equation over 2x minus y Z
equals 1 you can see if we add straight
down the X's are cancelling out now
because one's negative ones positive we
get positive y plus 9z equals 21 so what
I'm going to do now is going to bring
this equation over here and now we're
down to a system of two equations with
two variables so all we have to do now
is pick a variable to eliminate either
the Y's or the disease so in this case
I'm going to eliminate the Y's and what
I'm going to do is because this is 3y
I'm going to multiply this whole
equation times a negative 3 so if we
just distribute that negative 3 make
sure you do to the left middle of the
right the entire equation we get
negative 3y minus 27 Z is equal to
negative 63 now if we add these
two equations together you can see that
the 3y and the negative 3y those cancel
3z minus 20 z 27 z is negative 24 z and
15 minus 63 is how much let's do that on
the calculator so we've got negative 63
plus 15 which is negative 48 okay so
that's down to one variable one equation
all we have to do now is divide both
sides by negative 24 and you can see
that Z is equal to 2 so we went from
three variables three equations down to
two variables two equations down to one
variable one equation now we want to do
is want to work our way backwards we're
going to do back substitution so if Z
equals two you can put it either in for
this Z or this Z it doesn't matter which
one so I'm just going to go ahead and
put it into this one equation here so we
have 3y plus 3 instead of Z I'm going to
put 2 in equals 15 and that comes out to
6 plus 3y equals 15 if I subtract 6 from
both sides that gives us 9 okay and if
we divide both sides by 3 you can see
that Y is equal to 3 now all we have to
do we've got y&z is we can put it back
into one of the original equations it
has three variables and solve for X so
I'm going to go ahead and put it into
this top equation here this is X plus 2
times y which is 3 minus Z which is 2
and that equals 5 so let's just simplify
here we've got X plus 6 minus 2 equals 5
6 minus 2 is 4 and if I subtract 4 from
both sides I get x equals 1 so our final
solution we want to write as a triple
and it looks like this it's X comma Y
comma Z but in this case it's going to
be 1 3 & 2 so it's just alphabetical
order and that's your solution now if
you want to check your work all you have
to do is put it back in for each one of
these equations for XY and Z and you
should get 5 10 and 1 so if it makes all
the equations true you know this is the
common solution for all three equations
so if you want to know more about
solving systems of equations or you want
more practice check out the video right
there I'm going to have three equations
three variables I'm going to have three
examples that you can practice on your
or you can see some more how I would
approach those so check out that video
there otherwise I'll see you in the next
video